any suggestion by zalinski or anyone
else that we should we're going to
eventually have US troops there I can
tell the American people when I'm
president that will not happen we are
not going to send your sons and
daughters to Ukraine I am going to send
troops to our Southern border if you
look at the threats that we Face
terrorists have come in through our
Southern border I'm going to shut it
down I'm going to have the military and
I'm going to deport the people who've
come particularly under Biden who've
come from the Middle East come from all
these places now Biden wants $105
billion UH 60 most of that's Ukraine
including some of it going going to pay
pensions for bureaucrats and salaries
that is a totally ridiculous use of
American tax dollars he says he has
money for border to try to do and the
media repeat that when you look at it
what most of the money is is money to
process more illegal aliens into this
country how is that solving the problem
that's making the problem worse and what
does he do for the Indo Pacific a
pittance that is the top threat that we
Face we need to bring this war to an end